So now let's try to apply the concept
that we have learned to an actual cache.
We know that the main memory
in a computer is large and
very slow to access compared
to processor speed.
And also we know that there
is lots of spatial and
temporal locality present
in our data accesses.
Most programs exhibit a lot of
spatial and temporal locality.
So for an access to a memory location
what do you think we should do?
Should we go to the main memory for
every access?
Should we have a small memory inside the
processor core, and then we bring stuff
we access there so that next time
we need it, we can find it quickly?
Or should we have a huge memory
next to our processor chip,
because it won't fit
on the processor chip?
And then,
as we read from the main memory,
we bring everything into this
memory that is next to us.